bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte sur
LCP à l'ordre du jour un sujet très
sensible la protection de l'enfance une
délégation au droit de l'enfant a été
créé à l'Assemblée nationale le 6
décembre 2022 elle entend le juge
Édouard Durand se juge a pendant 17 ans
entendu la parole d'enfants il a
recueilli autant de témoignages sur
l'enfance maltraité aujourd'hui il est
qu'au président de la civisme la
commission indépendante sur l'inceste et
les violences sexuelles faites aux
enfants place tout de suite à une
audition exceptionnelle c'est un honneur
pour le juge des enfants que je suis
pour le coup président de la civisme et
à travers moi pour la civile elle-même
et tous ses membres d'être auditionnés
par la délégation au droit de l'enfant
de l'Assemblée nationale
si nouvelle et l'audition d'aujourd'hui
est le signal fort de
votre préoccupation concernant les
violences qui sont faites aux enfants et
notamment les violences sexuelles
puisque vous voulez bien nous
auditionner très rapidement je suis
accompagné de Benoît Legrand
administrateur hors-classe de l'État et
secrétaire général de la civilise et
d'Alice Gayraud rapporteur et chef de
cabinet
Nathalie Mathieu est retenu à jeun pour
la maison brut qui comme vous le savez
et à ce jour la seule association
spécialisée dans l'accueil des jeunes
filles victimes d'inceste
vous l'avez vous l'avez redit madame la
Présidente la civise a été créée d'abord
à l'initiative d'Adrien taquet
secrétaire d'État à la protection de
l'enfance en août 2020
dans un contexte particulier qui est
l'exemple donné par la commission
indépendante sur les violences de France
et dans le souci particulier
d'ouvrir un espace de témoignage à
toutes les personnes victimes de
violences sexuelles et notamment celle
qui ont le moins accès à la parole les
enfants handicapés et en janvier 2021 la
publication du livre de Camille Kouchner
a conduit à donner à la commission qui a
été confiée à Nathalie Mathieu et moi un
tournant un peu particulier
articulé autour de sa mission
fondamentale qui est de recueillir la
parole des personnes adultes des hommes
et des femmes qui ont été victimes de
viol et d'agression sexuelle dans leur
enfance
moi je suis juste des enfants vous
l'avez rappelé ma vie c'est de
recueillir la parole des enfants et
depuis deux ans je recueille la parole
des adultes qui sont devenus et
évidemment j'en tire des leçons
dans la prise de conscience de la
gravité de ces violences durant la vie
entière et des leçons plus
rétrospectives sur notre capacité y
compris les miennes à repérer et à
protéger les enfants au moment où ils
subissent des violences la commission
sauvée avait montré que parmi nous c'est
à dire ici même nécessairement mais
partout 5,5 millions de personnes
adultes avaient été victime de viols et
d'agressions sexuelles dans leur enfance
une personne sur dix et c'est notamment
à partir de ce chiffre si considérable
que nous pouvons dire que dans une
classe de 30 enfants il y a au moins 1 2
ou 3 enfants victimes de viol ou
d'agression sexuelle
et la civile le dit depuis sa création à
partir des données du ministère de
l'Intérieur et des grandes enquêtes de
victimes chaque année 160 000 enfants
sont victimes de violences sexuelles
notamment et principalement dans la
famille par l'inceste qui représente au
moins deux tiers de l'ensemble des
violences sexuelles faites aux enfants
vous savez ma passion aussi pour le
problème des violences conjugales et de
ses conséquences pour les enfants vous
en avez dit un mot dans votre
introduction
il faut vraiment prendre conscience pour
que que
prendre conscience que pour semblable la
maison n'est pas le lieu de la sécurité
mais de la confrontation à la mort et
c'est une très profonde inégalité entre
les êtres humains
fort de tout cela nous avons préparé des
janvier 2021 notre appel à témoignage et
nous l'avons ouvert officiellement le 21
septembre 2021
par les plateformes téléphoniques
confiées en métropole collectif et
ministre contre le viol et pour les
Français de l'outre-mer et de l'étranger
à l'association SOS crise
et dans les heures puis les jours qui
ont suivi les lignes étaient saturées
nous recevions des centaines et des
centaines d'appels
et les personnes disaient j'ai attendu
ce moment toute ma vie
des personnes parfois très âgées elles
ont 44 ans en moyenne
elles peuvent avoir 80-85 ans et ces
personnes vous disent en face à la
commission viennent parfois de très loin
j'ai attendu ce moment toute ma vie
parce que la civise recueille la parole
de ces personnes au nom de la société
tout entière et des pouvoirs publics et
donc que nous ne dissocions jamais
le recueil du témoignage
et la production de préconisations de
politiques publiques je pense d'ailleurs
et déjà j'anticipe sur ce que j'aurais
voulu vous dire en terminant mon propos
c'est à dire la presse civisme
que
ce besoin sera toujours aussi important
mais que pour fonctionner il faudra
qu'il soit associé à l'évaluation et à
la production de préconisations de
politiques publiques parce que chaque
personne qui vient témoigner à la civil
le dit toujours je le fais pour moi et
je le fais pour que les enfants ne
vivent plus ce que moi j'ai vécu je le
fais pour moi
la civisme n'est pas un tribunal
la civile n'est pas un hôpital
la civisme n'est pas un service social
la civil est un espace de reconnaissance
et nous sommes
structurés et grandis par ces
témoignages que nous recevons et quand
vous avez dans une réunion publique
comme à Paris par exemple nous l'avons
organisé au Palais de la femme il y a
200-300 personnes et puis à un moment
donné vous avez une femme qui a une
cinquantaine d'années qui se lève et qui
dit à partir du jour ou dans mon enfance
j'ai été violée j'ai pensé que j'avais
perdu toute dignité
elle s'adresse à ses frères et soeurs
d'infortune et elle dit en vous écoutant
je comprends que je n'ai jamais perdu ma
dignité et ce soir je la retrouve et si
la civisme peut produire ça c'est déjà
beaucoup
cela veut dire que la société a
progressé
que la civisme est la cristallisation
d'un progrès social et politique même
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
vous ou la société tout entière nous
demande de recueillir des témoignages 19
000 à ce jour ils ont ils augmentent
chaque jour donc depuis le 21 septembre
nous sommes passés de 16000 à 19000 à
peu près
et donc nous sommes capables de dire
nous vous croyons nous aurions dû vous
protéger c'est ce que je fais depuis 2
ans et aujourd'hui ça ne pose plus de
problème à la société on est capable de
comprendre que lorsqu'une personne vient
révéler des violences sexuelles
il faut la croire
et faire le constat de l'absence de
protection et de l'impunité des
agresseurs
et vous savez ce que j'ajoute à ceci
c'est que si aujourd'hui la société
est prête à dire à des adultes nous vous
croyons nous aurions dû vous protéger il
y a 50 ans
alors
l'implicite contenu dans cette
proposition consensuelle est de dire aux
enfants aujourd'hui je te crois je te
protège
et nous ne nous serions pas présentés
devant vous
sans être fidèle à cette parole des
témoins qui nous parlent c'est-à-dire
d'être tout de suite dans la
préconisation des politiques publiques
parce que c'est 160000 enfants victimes
de violences sexuelles chaque année ils
ne sont ni dans les tribunaux ni dans
les hôpitaux ni dans les services
sociaux vous savez que bonhomme allant
il condamnation par an ce qui décrit un
système d'impunité des agresseurs devant
la représentation nationale le juge
Édouard Durand dresse un état des lieux
terrible témoignage à la pluie il
explique aussi comment il travaille au
quotidien comment il a travaillé pendant
toutes ces années pour repérer et
signaler les crimes commis sur les
enfants alors je dis un mot de
l'organisation vous vous me l'avez
demandé madame la Présidente nous
comptons à peu près 25 27 membres
tous les métiers de la protection de
l'enfant sont représentés des médecins
des psychologues des avocats des
magistrats policiers gendarmes
responsable de politique publique de
services de protection de l'enfance et
victimes ou représentants d'associations
de victimes
nous travaillons en auditionnant des
experts dans notre sous-commission
pratique professionnelle protectrice la
sous-commission soins et accompagnement
la sous-commission
police justice et la sous-commission en
jeu de société
c'est ce qui nous a permis d'élaborer
dès nos conclusions intermédiaires vins
préconisations articulées autour de
quatre actions fondamentaux qui
structurent notre travail le premier
c'est le repérage des enfants victimes
le second le traitement judiciaire des
violences sexuelles le troisième la
réparation incluant le soin vous avez
raison c'est une priorité et le
quatrième et dernier et la prévention
je suis d'accord avec vous Madame la
Présidente la prévention et le repérage
sont indissociables quand nous faisons
du repérage nous faisons de la
prévention quand nous faisons de la
prévention nous faisons du repérage et
que dans les deux cas la seule chose qui
compte la seule chose que la société
peut attendre des professionnels qui
travaillent avec des enfants est
d'inspirer confiance aux enfants
victimes
chaque institutrice chaque CPE chaque
médecin scolaire chaque juge des enfants
chaque policier chaque assistante
sociale et bien sûr j'oublie des métiers
pourrait se fixer cet objectif inspirer
confiance aux enfants et vous vous
souvenez peut-être que la docteur Céline
Gréco Raphaël dans son livre la démesure
dit à partir du moment où la CPE m'a
attendu à la fin d'un cours je suis
devenu invincible
alors je ne vous répéterai pas nos vins
préconisations que vous connaissez que
vous avez bien voulu voulu rappeler
le repérage puisque c'est votre le
premier point qui attire votre attention
pour la CIVIS c'est le repérage par le
questionnement systématique
vous êtes spécialiste et
particulièrement engagé pour la
protection des enfants et vous
connaissez comme de nombreux
professionnels le tableau clinique des
enfants victimes de violences sexuelles
qui correspond à celui des enfants
victimes de violences conjugales et
peut-être aussi d'autres violences il
est possible de repérer par l'attention
la vigilance
au comportement aux attitudes de
l'enfant dans ces lieux de vie notamment
à l'école mais tous les enfants ne
présentent pas les mêmes signes au même
moment de la même manière avec la même
intensité de sorte que il serait
périlleux d'attendre d'être comme
professionnel
interpellé par un signe
donc et en cela nous ne faisons que nous
recommander des travaux de la Haute
Autorité de Santé et de la Mission
interministérielle de protection des
femmes victimes de violence l'ami prof
nous préconisons le repérage par le
questionnement systématique et c'est là
vous avez raison que la prévention et le
repérage sont indissociables parce que
ces séances d'éducation à la vie
sexuelle et affective nous aimons
ajouter le mot affectif dans cet
acronyme et ce vocable sont l'espace
privilégié où on peut parler aux enfants
de la vie affective
et peut-être de la sexualité mais
surtout de la loi et du corps et
on pourrait dire que la civil sonore
elle le doit notamment à l'une de ses
membres Marie rabattel d'avoir élaboré
une préconisation qui vise à protéger
tous les enfants à partir de la tension
particulière que nous devons aux enfants
handicapés qui comme vous le savez pour
un risque 2,9 fois plus élevé d'être
victime de viols et d'agressions
sexuelles
qui est celui de l'éveil des enfants à
l'intimité et notamment à l'intimité
corporelle
et de l'éveil des adultes et même des
professionnels au respect de l'intimité
des enfants et j'ai été très attentif à
deux informations qui nous ont été
données la première particulièrement
s'agissant des enfants handicapés que ce
sont des enfants à qui on ne demande
jamais
l'autorisation ou même un avis sur ce
qu'il pense des soins qu'on leur donne
ce qui est d'une manière de ne pas
prendre en compte leur intimité et
l'autre formule est celle d'un expert
pédopsychiatre qui attirait notre
attention en nous disant
remarquez que dans l'existence des
humains
il arrive un jour et ce jour c'est
l'anniversaire des 7 ans où on dit à un
enfant si un adulte
te dit monte dans ma voiture je vais te
donner des bonbons tu dois lui dire non
et pendant les 7 années qui auront
précédé on ne lui aura renseigné qu'une
chose à dire oui
il y a donc une mission très importante
dans l'éducation
à la vie affective et sexuelle à
condition sur le modèle de ce document
que vous connaissez et qui reste très
actuel mon corps c'est mon corps d'être
centré sur la loi
et la violence
et j'ajouterai sur l'éducation à la vie
sexuelle et affective
principalement dans ce champ mais dans
tous les autres que nous devons être
extrêmement vigilants aux besoins
fondamentaux des enfants vous savez que
j'avais participé en 2016-2017 à la
démarche de consensus sur le besoin
fondamentaux des enfants en protection
de l'enfance et que ces séances doivent
être organisées dans le respect du
développement et de l'âge de l'enfant
on ne parle pas de la même manière du
corps de l'affectivité de la sexualité
et on ne montre pas les mêmes images un
enfant de maternelle vous l'avez dit je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est le bon
moment pour commencer ou à une
adolescente ou un adolescent de 16 ou 17
ans
le ministère de l'Éducation nationale a
publié récemment le rapport sur la mise
en place de ces séances nous savons
qu'elles sont insuffisamment mises en
place
nous savons que le contenu de ce qui est
dispensé est insuffisamment vérifié
et c'est pourquoi
je pense que votre délégation pourrait
très utilement et avec une très grande
puissance
recommandée ce que pour ma part
j'aimerais même que la civise fasse si
elle en avait le temps nous en parlerons
tout à l'heure du temps qui passe
pouvoir élaborer un guide consensuel
d'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle qui respecterait les étapes du
développement de l'enfant et de son âge
s'agissant de la cellule de soutien aux
professionnels c'est la préconisation
que nous avons formulé
dès que nous avons formulé la
préconisation sur le repérage
systématique et je me permets d'insister
que le repérage systématique vaut pour
les adultes que ces enfants sont devenus
l'espace médical est un espace
privilégié pour ça mais pas seulement
parce que ce que nous constatons aussi
nous à la civisme en recevant près de 20
000 témoignages c'est que les personnes
qui ont été victimes de violences
sexuelles dans leur enfant
continue de vivre dans une forme sinon
de solitude en tout cas
d'incompréhension par leur entourage de
la gravité des violences et de l'impact
qui perdure
donc le repérage qui permet un dialogue
en confiance et fondamental la
contrepartie de cette exigence à l'égard
des professionnels c'est la cellule de
soutien
évidemment que le gouvernement est
annoncé qu'il allait reprendre cette
préconisation et pour la civisme un très
grand motif de satisfaction
je me permets très humblement d'attirer
l'attention de la délégation droit de
l'enfant sur le fait que notre sens
cette cellule de soutien aux
professionnels
doit être garante de ce que j'appelle
une doctrine nationale
c'est-à-dire un message
unique et cohérent
unique cohérent et volontariste
résolument du côté de la protection du
parti pris de la protection des enfants
posez la question croire l'enfant le
protéger instantanément
pour que cette cellule garantisse une
doctrine nationale il faut qu'elle soit
nationale unique constitué de
professionnels qui pourraient très
utilement se référer au livret que la
civisme vient de publier
qui est notre livret de formation
repérer et signalé qui s'appuie sur un
court métrage réalisé par Johanna Bedot
Mélissa et les autres et qui a déjà été
téléchargé
5000 unités par les professionnels dans
sur l'ensemble du territoire national ce
qui correspond déjà à la mort d'une
doctrinationale alors je sais que parmi
les projets il y a l'idée que cette
cellule pourrait être départementalisée
et juge des enfants j'ai été attaché à
des territoires à Marseille à Bobigny à
Draguignan et ailleurs et je sais bien à
quel point les réalités
locales sont fondamentales et doivent
être prises en compte mais je sais aussi
que d'une part un médecin sait déjà
qu'il peut appeler son confrère ou sa
concert spécialement référente des
violences faites aux enfants sur son
territoire donc ce serait pas une
nouveauté et que un professionnel
ayant des responsabilités
institutionnelles dans une nuit à peine
ou une grippe par exemple est toujours
aussi déterminée par des contraintes
locales qui vont conditionner sa réponse
c'est pourquoi il faut que cette cellule
soit une nouveauté
qu'elle ne soit pas rattachée à quelque
chose qui existe déjà mais qu'elle soit
porteuse de cette doctrine je le dis
aussi clairement que je le pense et je
vous prie de m'en excuser sur les soins
spécialisés en psychotrema alors sur les
UAPE évidemment
la cellule avait la civise pardon après
préconisée ce référent à cela à ce que
le Adrien taquin avait déjà fait dans
son travail ministériel au déploiement
des usapèdes et je me cantonnerai à deux
remarques trois remarques la première
le documentaire que infrarouge a diffusé
il y a quelques jours et que vous avez
sans doute vu mesdames et messieurs les
députés montrent à quel point
la protection des enfants et la lutte
contre l'impunité des violences
sexuelles exigent un traînés au niveau
de compétences une société comme la
nôtre arrive à le comprendre pour le
droit des affaires le droit de
l'environnement
et tout autre chose éminemment sérieuse
elle est peut-être en train de le
comprendre pour ce que j'appelle les
violences de la maison les violences de
l'intime violence conjugale violence
sexuelle inceste
deuxièmement les UAPE ont besoin de
professionnels qui soient réellement
présents dans les services c'est à dire
des moyens
qui permettront de garantir que non
seulement les structures existent et
qu'on peut dire qu'elles existent mais
qu'elles sont dotées de professionnels
qui accueillent les enfants et je notre
première visite était à lui à peine de
Nantes j'ai pour la médecin qui l'a
dirige et pour toutes ces concerts et
confrères un infini respect et
je sais la qualité du travail qu'il est
fond
sur les soins spécialisés
je vous disais mon interrogation
rétrospective lorsque j'ai reçu la
parole de ces enfants dans les tribunaux
où étaient juges des enfants je me
demande désormais si j'ai été capable de
me représenter l'horreur de leur
existence
et
au moment de leur enfant l'intensité de
leur souffrance
et du fait que cette souffrance durait
tout au long de leur vie
recueillir les témoignages des personnes
adultes qui le font confiance à la
civisme nous permet de dire
que il existe une autre injustice très
grande dans la société c'est que les
soins spécialisés en psychotroma existe
et qu'ils ne sont pas dispensés
alors instantanément ça éveille en moi
le souvenir d'une situation quand
j'étais juge des enfants une petite
fille
victime de violences conjugales de viol
conjugal devant les enfants d'inceste de
violences physiques pour toute la
fratrie et qui était confié à une
famille d'accueil et qui faisait des
cauchemars traumatiques toutes les nuits
et qui avaient l'impression que son
agresseur son père était dans sa chambre
j'avais écrit dans mon jugement elle
doit bénéficier de soins spécialisés en
psychotrema on m'avait répondu querelle
de chapelle
et hélas je crois pouvoir dire que ce
mécanisme de défense est toujours
extrêmement puissant or ces soins
spécialisés existe ils ne sont pas
dispensés bien sûr que ça impose que
vous votiez les budgets nécessaires pour
que les médecins soient formés
et qu'ils aient les conditions
matérielles pour dispenser ses soins
mais la protection des enfants victimes
et des adultes qu'ils deviennent coûtera
toujours moins cher que l'impunité qui
est désagresseur et que la souffrance
perpétuelle
le coût social sera toujours beaucoup
moins élevé la civise espère pouvoir
préconiser proposer aussi précisément
que possible un parcours de soins pour
les enfants victimes et les adultes
qu'ils deviennent
vous m'avez interrogé sur le protocole
féminicide
et évidemment je ne peux que moi aussi
me référer à ce modèle et à rendre
hommage tout particulièrement à
Ernestine renais responsable de
l'Observatoire des violences faites aux
femmes du département de la
Seine-Saint-Denis et membre de la
civisme qu'il avait élaboré avec les
services de soins le service de la
docteur Clémentine Rapaport et les
magistrats du parquet et du siège du
tribunal de grande instance tribunal
judiciaire de Bobigny et c'est un
excellent modèle
parce que nous voyons à partir des
dispositifs spécialisés qui ont été
créés en Seine-Saint-Denis pour lutter
contre la violence conjugale que
ces dispositifs
ne dissocient jamais la mise en sécurité
de l'enfant ou du parent victime
et le traitement de l'autorité parentale
et que ce protocole féminicide répond
aussi à une des préoccupations à
laquelle nous sommes en train de
travailler pour s'agissant des violences
sexuelles c'est que il est la garantie
de la prise en compte instantanée de la
souffrance psychique de l'enfant
spontanément on pense que lorsqu'un
enfant a vécu des violences aussi graves
que
l'assassinat de sa mère par son père ou
qu'un viol incestueux il est préférable
de le laisser dans son le milieu qu'il
connaît le mieux sans penser que cet
univers qu'il connaît le mieux peut être
la scène de crime elle-même
sans penser que les personnes qui
l'entourent et qui sans doute le plus
souvent ont beaucoup de bonnes
intentions pour lui ou elle
sont insuffisamment formés à l'état de
stress post-traumatique et aux
reviviscences traumatiques et donc ce
protocole est un très bon modèle on
pourrait y réfléchir pour les violences
sexuelles garantir la sécurité de
l'enfant et les soins en urgence mais
évoquer le protocole féminicite c'est
instantanément évoqué la question de
l'autorité parentale
la civise a fait dès le 27 octobre 2021
dans son premier avis sur l'inceste
parental à propos des mers en lutte
trois préconisations
parce que dès le 21 janvier 2021 nous
avons reçu des centaines et des
centaines d'appels au secours de parents
protecteur le plus souvent des mers qui
disait mon enfant m'a révélé être
victime d'inceste parental j'ai cru
faire mon devoir en allant au tribunal
au commissariat à la gendarmerie à
l'hôpital on m'a accusé de mentir mon
enfant est obligé d'aller chez son
agresseur préconisations numéro 1
suspendre les poursuites pénales pour
non représentation d'enfants lorsqu'une
enquête pénale est en cours contre un
parent pour inceste
tout le monde ne fait pas l'objet d'une
enquête pénale pour inceste
même trop peu de personnes puisque les
160 000 enfants sont invisibles
quand il y a cette enquête il faut bien
que l'enfant soit quelque part si
possible qu'il soit chez le parent qui
ne fait pas l'objet de la révélation de
violence ça paraît aller de soi nous
avons été contestés mais nous assumons
cette préconisation qui est résolument
du côté des enfants le décret du 23
novembre 2021 la traduite dans le code
de procédure pénale en disant un parent
ne peut pas être poursuit pour non
représentations d'enfants tant que toute
la lumière n'a pas été faite sur les
violences à léguer contre l'enfant le
problème est que 70% des plaintes sont
classées sans suite
et qu'il faudra bien à un moment ou un
autre
comprenne plus au sérieux la parole des
enfants car on ne peut pas continuer
d'envoyer des injonctions paradoxales
faites-nous confiance mais ne nous
parlez pas de viol
protégez vos enfants
mais ne nous parlez pas d'inceste
signalez les violences sexuelles faites
aux enfants mais vous risquez des
sanctions disciplinaires pour y mixer en
émission dans la vie privée des familles
une injonction paradoxale ça paralyse
troisième de nos préconisations retrait
automatique de l'autorité parentale en
cas de condamnation pour inceste et je
réponds
immédiatement à la question que vous
m'avez posée madame la Présidente oui
les préconisations que la civisme fait
dans son champ d'étude les violences
sexuelles faites aux enfants ont
vocation à être étendue à l'ensemble des
violences faites aux enfants incluant
les violences conjugales
et pourquoi nous faisons ces
préconisations parce que il est déjà
prévu dans le Code civil qu'une
juridiction pénale puisse retirer
l'autorité parentale un parent condamné
pour inceste mais c'est rarissime
comme c'est rare ici dans les cas de
violences conjugales et même de
féminicides que parfois c'était même pas
demandé par le Service de Protection de
l'enfance ou l'avocat qui le représente
c'est donc ce que j'appelle depuis 15
ans maintenant je ne vous surprendrai
pas une législation plus intéressante
et je vous dis très simplement madame et
messieurs les députés le fond de ma
pensée
il y a des situations où vous ne pas
vous ne pouvez pas voter des lois
en consentant à ce que leur mise en
oeuvre soit aléatoire selon les
représentations que les professionnels
chargés de l'appliquer se feront de la
violence et de la protection des
victimes de violence
plutôt que de dire la cour d'assis peut
retirer l'autorité parentale il suffit
de changer un mot dans le Code civil et
d'écrire la cour d'assise retire
l'autorité parentale on dit que c'est un
constitutionnel on dit que c'est
inconventionnel aucun principe n'est
contraire à la raison
et il n'y a pas de transgression plus
grave de l'autorité parentale que de
violer sa fille ou son fils alors pour
passer le cap de la constitutionnalité
de la conventionnalité je le sais on
vous demandera d'ajouter sauf décision
contraire et spécialement motivée entre
ces deux préconisations il y a la
troisième la deuxième en réalité qui est
la suspension de plein droit législation
impérative de l'autorité parentale et du
droit de visite et d'hébergement du
parent faisant l'objet de poursuites
pénal pour inceste sur le modèle de la
législation qui a fait suite aux
crenelles sur les violences conjugales
70% des plaintes sont classées sans
suite quand les plaintes ne sont pas
classées sans suite que le procureur de
la République demande à un just
instruction de mettre en examen un
parent pour viol incestueux ou saisi un
tribunal correctionnel pour agression
sexuelle incestueuse nous pensons qu'il
est légitime que le législateur prévoit
dans la loi que jusqu'au jugement
l'autorité parentale et le droit de
visite des bergement seront suspendus de
plaindre à
la question est qui veut ton protéger
si c'est l'enfant je pense que vous
pouvez écrire les choses de cette façon
là dans le Code civil ou le code de
procédure pénale
alors s'agissant de l'obligation de
signalement des médecins et je
m'arrêterai pardon d'avoir été trop long
je dirais deux choses la première
se trouvait en présence d'un enfant
qui vous révèle qu'il est victime de
viol et d'agression sexuelle notamment
d'un cest
et de l'ordre de l'insoutenable et un
humain normal veut mettre à distance de
lui les images que produisent les mots
que prononce l'enfant
et les médecins la chass le redit
d'ailleurs sont d'une peau dans une
position privilégiée pour le repérage
mais il faut que pour eux comme un tout
autre professionnel pas moins qu'aux
autres professionnels les règles
déontologiques et légales qui
structurent leur exercice professionnel
soit clair
car l'insécurité n'est de règle confuse
et vous savez
aussi bien que moi et sans doute mieux
que moi compte tenu de toutes les
personnes qui ont dû avant la civisme
vous demandez d'être en faveur de cette
obligation de signalement que
l'articulation de la législation et
d'énormes réglementaires déontologiques
applicable au médecin
génère des règles extrêmement confuse
j'ai compris que je ne dois pas être
enquêteur mes médecins est-ce que j'ai
des suspicions ou une certitude est-ce
que je suis dans un cas où je dois
signaler faire une information
préoccupante ou risquais-je des
poursuites pour émission dans la vie
privée des familles il faut clarifier la
loi et qu'il soit écrit très simplement
que le médecin comme tout autre
professionnel a une obligation de
signalement quand il suspecte qu'un
enfant est victime de violence telle que
les violences sexuelles
le silence ces larmes de l'agresseur
il faut amorcer la chaîne de la
protection
et que l'enfant comprenne que nul n'est
intimidé par le silence imposé par la
graissaie mais chaque exigence imposait
un professionnel implique une protection
et donc la protection contre les
poursuites disciplinaires il est anormal
que des médecins protecteurs soient
sanctionnés pour avoir voulu protéger
des enfants alors même qu'on ne leur dit
vous ne devez pas vous prendre pour des
enquêteurs donc à quel moment
doivent-ils amorcer la chaîne de la
protection sinon au moment où il se
disent il est possible que cet enfant
soit victime de violence si nous voulons
protéger les enfants protégeons les
parents protecteurs et les
professionnels protecteurs je vous
remercie de votre attention
voilà pour ces propos édifiants du juge
Edouard Durand devant la délégation au
droit des enfants place tout de suite
aux questions nombreuses des députés
je vous propose de laisser la parole à
un représentant de chaque groupe
politique dans un premier temps pour une
durée de 2 minutes chers collègues
pour débuter madame dubreira
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur juge
et qu'au Président je tiens à vous
remercier vraiment de votre présence et
cette audition dans le cadre délégation
installé par Adrien taquet en mars 2021
cette commission indépendante sur
l'inceste et les violences sexuelles
faites aux enfants que vous co présidez
avec Nathalie Mathieu fonctionne depuis
18 mois vous l'avez rappelé une personne
sur 10 a été victime de violences
sexuelles dans son enfance 5 millions et
demi de femmes et d'hommes 160 000
enfants sont victimes devient sexuel
chaque année votre mission est
d'accompagner un changement de société
pour permettre la France de s'engager de
manière déterminée pour une protection
des mineurs par l'instauration d'une
culture de la prévention et de la
protection vous vous attachez à rendre
ces jeunes visibles à partager leur
traumatisme à faire prendre conscience
de la gravité de la situation mais aussi
à formuler des mesures pour lutter
contre les auteurs de ses actes ignobles
en octobre 2021 dans un premier rapport
vous avez fait des préconisations
importantes sur l'autorité parentale et
le droit de visite et d'hébergement du
parent poursuivi et retrait systématique
en cas de condamnation le garde des
sceaux et la secrétaire d'État chargée
de l'enfance ce sont prononcés pour une
évolution de la réglementation nous
l'appelons de nos vœux et nous serons
rendez vous pour modifier la loi je
souhaiterais d'autre part avoir votre
avis sur l'impact psychologique des
enfants exposés aux violences
intrafamiliales et leur nécessaire
protection elle se superposent souvent
violence physique et sont annonciatrices
de violence à venir sous la
précédentement nature nous avons
travaillé avec ma collègue Marie
tamarelle verhaeg nous avons fait des
propositions pour suspendre l'autorité
parentale et le droit de visite pour
toute poursuite ou qu'on nation
reconnaître l'enfant victime pour son
accompagnement avec un avocat et sa
prise en charge psychologique en
septembre 2022 de la restitution de
votre appel à témoignage qui a duré un
an
vous d'hommes et de femmes vous leur
avez garanti la possibilité d'avoir des
soins depuis des années nous avons
tenter d'améliorer les signalements et
nous nous confrontons à la réticence des
professionnels évoquant d'une part le
secret médical d'autre part la délation
comment pensez-vous pouvoir avancer sur
ce sujet d'autre part vous avez mis en
place un outil de formation ensemble des
professionnels pouvez-vous nous en dire
plus sur les moyens de détection
proposés ainsi que sur les attentes et
le retour de ses professionnels ainsi
que sur les numéros d'appel comment
gérez-vous les liens avec les parents
suite aux annonces des enfants sur ses
appels téléphoniques et avec les
instances concernées je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour le groupe LFI
monsieur gaillard
monsieur le co-président tout d'abord si
un vous remercier en tant que
professionnel la protection de l'enfance
et je pense au nom d'un certain nombre
de professionnels de la protection de
l'enfance pour votre travail et le
travail de votre commission et pour les
propos que vous avez tenues en
particulier sur les moyens en
particulier sur la doctrine nationale et
ça pose la question de la
recentralisation de la compétence de la
protection de l'enfant dans notre pays
et puis en particulier aussi sur les
difficultés à travailler recueillir
accepter parfois vivre avec vous êtes
juste des enfants
les paroles qu'on recueille les
situations avec lesquelles on travaille
et justement ma question en tout cas la
remarque que je tiens à faire est en
rapport avec les professionnels je suis
député de La Réunion comme ma collègue
Karine Le Bon à côté de moi la civise a
prévenu de venir normalement premier
semestre 2023 à la Réunion et à Mayotte
dans cette optique je me fais un peu le
porte-parole des professionnels de la de
la protection de l'enfance et de tous
ceux qui gravitent autour de la
protection de l'enfance
qui réclame des formations adaptées
depuis longtemps et dans le processus
initial de formation des travailleurs
sociaux par exemple mais également des
formations adaptées tout au long du
cursus professionnel que ce soit la
maternité à l'école au niveau des
avocats des juges des éducateurs
spécialisés des éducatrices ou
éducateurs de jeunes enfants des
assistants sociales en fait tous
réclament d'être formés au repérage vous
l'avez vous en avez parlé repéra des
violences que subissent ces enfants
c'est la première étape nécessaire de
notre point de vue c'est former ce qu'on
pourrait appeler les travailleurs de la
première ligne qui sont capables de
repérer d'orienter d'offrir un cadre
sécurisé aux victimes et de sortir du
fait noir c'est une expression
réunionnaise de sortir de l'obscurité
finalement la question des violences
sexuelles faites aux enfants les
chiffres que vous que vous nous donnez
sont très claires à ce niveau là et donc
si on est dans cette dynamicale c'est
très bien qu'on soit au niveau collectif
il faut derrière des moyens des
formations adaptées pour les personnes
qui puissent prendre en charge
problématique je vous remercie
je vous remercie pour les républicains
monsieur portier
dans les freins si on peut les résumer
qui ont été évoqués ces dernières années
on a
trouvé très fréquemment une faible
participation des enseignants un manque
de clarté du cadre et des attendus aussi
à l'égard des enseignants et puis
finalement le sens qu'on donne à cette
enseignant à cette enseignement dans le
projet des établissements dans le projet
même de l'éducation nationale ma
question est donc double c'est
pensez-vous aujourd'hui que les
enseignants sont suffisamment armés pour
porter cette éducation à la sexualité
que vous appelez de vos vœux et
de manière plus plus prudente est-ce que
la démultiplication des outils
aujourd'hui des circulaires des
instructions des va des make-up en
toussant sur beaucoup de thématiques qui
sont tout important ne pourraient pas
décourager d'après vous les enseignants
eux-mêmes est-ce qu'il y a pas un
travail de rationalisation de tous ces
outils comment les mener merci
merci beaucoup pour le groupe modem
monsieur Balanant
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président pour votre exposé
j'ai pas pu arriver au début mais j'ai
eu une bonne partie et j'ai vu vos
chiffres et vos chiffres ils sont et
pharaons quelque part
on est sur quelque chose qui est un
désastre sanitaire et social et culturel
pour notre pays et donc il faut qu'on
avance il faut qu'on réagisse très vite
je j'ai été très touché parce que vous
avez dit sur l'âge de 7 ans et la
question de ce qu'on appelle souvent
l'âge de raison de nos enfants
c'est c'est terrible ce fait que nos
enfants commenceraient à avoir cette
interrogation à partir de 7 ans et que
avant ça serait tabou et je pense que
c'est là qu'il faut commencer c'est à
dire que la vie l'éducation à la vie
sexuelle affective elle doit commencer
sans doute peut-être dès la maternelle
c'est ça me semble évident et on voit
encore aujourd'hui les freins sur ce
sujet là moi je crois c'est la
conviction que j'aide pour avoir
travaillé depuis un moment maintenant
sur la question de du droit des enfants
que c'est justement l'angle mort
c'est-à-dire que expliquer à nos enfants
qu'ils ont des droits c'est ce que nous
ne savons pas faire dans notre pays et à
partir du moment où on ne connaît pas
ses droits on est dans l'incapacité
d'exprimer
la teinte qu'on a pu avoir puisqu'on ne
connaît pas ses droits et j'aimerais
avoir votre votre avis sur cette idée de
de multiplier de massifier
la
l'idée de de dire ces droits aux enfants
et je pense que on peut aussi justement
répondre à
cette idée de faire de l'éducation
sexuelle et affective par les droits par
l'explication à un enfant de ce qu'est
son corps de ce qui évidemment mais
aussi du droit qu'il en a à disposer la
façon dont il peut en disposer et je
crois un angle mort de de la façon de
travailler que quelque chose que nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui et ensuite le
corollaire c'est que je pense que et
vous l'avez un peu dit c'est qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une filière juridique très
organisée autour du droit de l'enfant et
ça veut dire sans doute et aujourd'hui
je crois que c'est pas suffisamment le
cas d'avoir des avocats spécialisés du
droit de l'enfant et donc on avait été
un certain nombre avec la présidente
assez le temps est passé à porter juste
la question de l'automaticité de la
représentation d'un avocat pour les
enfants
que l'enfant puisse avoir un avocat à
chaque fois parce que quand il y a un
problème avec ses parents par définition
si c'est l'avocat des parents il y a
quelque chose qui qui ne va pas
excusez-moi d'avoir été trop long
j'avais pas vu le j'avais pas vu le
chrono donc j'ai un peu débordé je
veille pour le groupe socialiste madame
Santiago
monsieur monsieur le Président de la
civisme cher Edouard de mon parcours de
vice-présidente du conseil départemental
du Val-de-Marne chargé de la prévention
de la protection de l'enfant en qualité
de chef de fil d'une politique publique
majeure pour les départements porté
durant 12 années où nous avons pu avoir
ensemble de nombreux échanges écologues
durant toutes ces années de membres du
CNPE puis de députés depuis septembre
2020 et de ce riche parcours atypique où
j'ai trop souvent entendu et croisé ce
que vous avez formant formidablement
bien décrit l'indicible
j'ai vu la souffrance des petites
victimes nous l'avons accompagné du
mieux possible et aujourd'hui il est
essentiel et je le redis devant mes
collègues je le dis souvent en séance il
y a urgence lorsqu'il s'agit des
victimes des petites victimes en France
de nos enfants à protéger aussi je
n'aborderai qu'un seul point et qui
mérite du coup j'attends votre éclairage
chez Edouard pour rappel en mars 2021
j'ai présenté plusieurs amendements lors
d'un débat sur le texte de Madame billon
après la PPL que j'avais déposée en
décembre 2020 et qui a été voté en
première lecture en février 2021 à
l'unanimité portant sur les violences
sexuelles faites aux mineurs nous
abordions pour la première fois le
consentement concernant le seuilda sur
les violences sexuelles et les questions
de l'inceste à l'Assemblée nationale
souvenir d'un très beau combat
parlementaire mais dans l'amendement
déposé en mars 2021 j'abordais cette
question que j'avais souvent rencontrée
en acteur de terrain qui était une de
vos préconisations à savoir qui était
donc à cette époque là l'observation que
nous devions protéger les enfants lors
d'une parole qui avait pu être donné sur
des violences sexuelles faites à un
enfant dans le cadre de la DVH et du
parents protecteur ce à quoi le garde je
finis ce à quoi le garde des sceaux en
mars 2021 a été défavorable il l'a
rejeté cet amendement quand vous l'avez
présenté par la suite comme un une
recommandation par la CIVIS ça a été
suivi des faits ce que je voudrais
savoir et donc du coup gros impact par
rapport au législateur mais ce que je
voudrais vous demander en fait pour
finir c'est que je voudrais savoir si
toutes les recommandations sont
travaillées simple garde des sceaux pour
que nous législateur y compris quand on
fait les demandes et qu'on avait bien
perçu les problématiques on puisse être
suivis dans l'intérêt général du travail
législatif avec les enfants et qu'on ne
soit pas avec des questions comme on a
pu les rencontrer en mars 2021 et je
sais que vous le savez on a souvent
parlé ensemble
merci Isabelle pour le groupe écologique
madame Pasquini
madame la Présidente Monsieur le coup
président le repérage des situations
d'inceste et de violence sexuelle dans
les enfants sans victime on la dit reste
difficile nous devons mieux identifier
les signaux d'alerte et si la parole des
enfants doit être libérée le personnel
qui la reçoit doit être mieux outillée
dans ce contexte l'école pourrait être
un lieu de repérage privilégié mais
recueillir la parole des enfants demande
un cadre et ce cadre nécessite du temps
et des moyens or il y a de moins en
moins d'infirmiers d'assistance sociaux
de psychologues et de médecins scolaires
donc nombre de situations de violence et
d'inceste risque de passer à la trappe à
cause de ce sous-effectif permanent si
un enfant surdit ses victimes d'inceste
en moyenne deux élèves par classe sont
potentiellement concernés les
professionnels de la médecine scolaire
demandent désespérément plus de moyens
le repérage de ces situations devrait se
faire au travers de visites médicales
obligatoires et grâce à l'oeil attentif
des professionnels qui toujours les
élèves pensez-vous que cela soit
suffisant et réellement applicable vu le
travail dans l'urgence que son contrat
de faire ses acteurs et comme le disait
mon collègue pensez-vous que les
enseignants soient assez formés sur ce
sujet et armé lorsqu'une situation se
présente
merci beaucoup et pour finir ce premier
tour de table madame Lebon pour le
groupe Geder merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le coprésident chers collègues
à la Réunion 4000 enfants seraient
victimes d'inceste chaque année et à la
Réunion il n'existe que deux salles
Mélanie
ces salles sont intégrées au parcours de
soins hospitaliers elles sont situées
dans le service de victimologie des
hôpitaux de Saint-Denis au nord de l'île
et de Saint-Pierre au sud dans vos
conclusions intermédiaires datées du 31
mars 2022 vous mentionnez que dans le
cadre du second plan de lutte contre les
violences faites aux enfants 2020-2022
le secrétaire d'État chargé de l'enfance
et des familles a prévu de généraliser
les unités d'accueil pédiatrique enfant
en danger à l'ensemble à l'ensemble du
territoire il n'y a pas d'uape à la
Réunion malgré l'annonce Adrien taquet
en 2020 lors de sa visite sur le
territoire cependant il y a bien deux
services de victimologie qui font un
travail notable il faut d'ailleurs
compter un mois d'attente pour obtenir
un rendez-vous sauf urgence dans ce même
rapport vous recommandez le déploiement
d'une salle Mélanie par compagnie dans
les zones de gendarmerie à la Réunion il
semble que la stratégie soit tout autre
puisque aucune scène est située dans les
locaux des forces de l'ordre police ou
gendarmerie est-ce judicieux si l'on
souhaite assurer un parcours judiciaire
adapté aux enfants recueillir leurs
paroles dans des conditions propices à
un témoignage de qualité et avant
l'audition il y a la prononciation des
faits par l'enfant lui-même par un
parent ou par un tiers extérieur à la
famille s'agissant des médecins en
novembre 2014 à la SAS indiquait que la
maltraitance des enfants était
sous-déclarée vous l'avez dit par les
médecins en France avec à peine 5% des
signalements provenant du secteur
médical l'ordre des médecins justifie
souvent la posture des professionnels
par le risque de représailles qui
existent il est réel en tant
qu'enseignante j'ai également été
confronté à ce type de situation quelle
préconisations apportées pour protéger
l'identité de l'auteur de signalements
qui soit médecin enseignants voisins
amis de la famille ne serait-il pas
possible de garantir l'anonymisation de
ces personnes je vous remercie
merci beaucoup chers collègues monsieur
le juge vous laisse répondre à cette
première salle de question si vous le
voulez bien je vous remercie
d'un certain point de vue l'ampleur
l'amplitude de vos questions et des
montre la confiance que vous accordez à
la civisme
je vais essayer d'être à la hauteur de
la tâche les regroupant aussi
aussi précisément que possible
peut-être dans une sorte de d'ordre
chronologique si nous essayons de suivre
un enfant victime
Avant la Révélation jusqu'à la jusqu'à
l'âge adulte
si je devais commencer par
l'étape qui précède le repérage et la
révélation je retiendrai d'abord la
question que madame la députée du
brichira bien voulu poser sur le les
violences conjugales donc
je vous remercie d'avoir fait ce lien
car il est extrêmement important à plus
d'un titre
les mécanismes de la violence sont les
mêmes la stratégie de l'agresseur et la
même l'impact psychotromatique et du
même ordre et la prévalence se retrouve
la violence est toujours un instrument
pour obtenir le pouvoir
il passe aussi par le sexuel et il y a
en effet dans les violences conjugales
un risque beaucoup plus élevé d'inceste
sur la fille par le violon conjugal
c'est documenté
et s'agissant des violences conjugales
tout particulièrement nous savons que
l'impact traumatique sur l'enfant et de
l'ordre de l'exposition de l'enfant à
une scène de guerre ou de terrorisme
que notamment parce que
il implique ce que la psychologue
karenzalli appelle un conflit de
protection et un conflit de loyauté et
qu'un enfant m'aime tout petit doit
résoudre un dilemme
extrêmement difficile dans un temps très
court est-ce que je me protège est-ce
que je protège ma mère est-ce que je
protège mon père
et sa désorganise
le psychisme et le développement
nous sommes donc face à une réalité
extrêmement massive qui a des
conséquences extrêmement graves et
durable sur le bien-être et le
développement des enfants et vous savez
que
on retrouve le docteur berger le dit
dans sa clinique des enfants les plus
violents parmi les enfants les plus
violents et notamment délinquants une
sur-représentation d'enfants victimes de
violence conjugales il faut absolument
le prendre au sérieux le problème est
que nous ne voulons pas toucher à la
parentalité
et que on fait comme si ce qui se
passait dans la conjugalité et ce qui se
passait dans la parentalité n'était pas
liée alors que ce sont deux problèmes
indissociables dans la vie réelle des
humains réels et pas imaginaires
et que
je ne m'explique pas pourquoi
face à des sujets
qui transgressent la loi
et notamment la loi sur l'autorité
parentale c'est-à-dire leur devoir de
protection et d'éducation
on ne prévoit pas de leur retirer les
moyens juridiques de perpétuer la
violence et l'emprise même après la
séparation par l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale voilà pourquoi je dis aussi
depuis très longtemps et je ne suis pas
le seul
qu'il faut aussi législation impérative
dans les violences conjugales
et qu'il faut écrire dans le Code civil
que lorsqu'il y a des violences
conjugales l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale est attribué exclusivement aux
parents victime et que les droits de
visite et d'hébergement les rencontrent
entre le parent violent et l'enfant
s'ils sont elles sont maintenus ne
peuvent l'être que dans un espace de
rencontre protégé
parce qu'il suffit d'un regard
pour sur victimiser une personne déjà
victime de violence
donc je vous remercie d'avoir posé cette
question et vous voyez à quel point je
m'y implique parce que en effet ces dit
depuis si longtemps je vois pas pourquoi
on continue d'opposer des principes à la
protection des enfants réels
nous les interprétons mal aucun principe
n'a jamais été pensé pour générer
l'impunité des agresseurs
alors l'étape d'après bien sûr c'est le
repérage
parce que dans la stratégie de
l'agresseur telle qu'elle a été
conceptualisée par le Collectif
féministe contre le viol et un estime
renais manuel Piat Marie-France Casalis
c'est-à-dire ce qu'on retrouve dans les
récits des victimes de violences
sexuelles notamment d'inceste et de
violences conjugales il y a toujours les
mêmes étapes il isole la victime il crée
un climat de peur et de terreur il passe
à l'acte il impose le silence il inverse
la culpabilité il recherche des alliés
c'est-à-dire nous et il assure son
impunité
comment voulez-vous qu'un enfant victime
de violence
d'inceste pour ce qui concerne la
civisme dans ce cas particulier de
lui-même d'elle-même sorte du silence
s'il n'y a pas un adulte
qui vient inspirer confiance on m'a vous
savez dans quand
évidemment dans mon engagement et en
tant que magistrat je fréquente des
juristes et des futurs juristes donc y
compris des élèves et notamment d'élèves
de avocat
et j'ai su très récemment que dans un
des cours dans une école d'avocats on
disait si un enfant révèle des violences
il faut lui dire tu sais que la personne
dont tu parles risque d'aller en prison
vous voyez pourquoi je parle d'une
doctrine nationale
parce qu'on peut c'est très intéressant
de concevoir moi je suis très heureux
mes collègues aussi c'est très c'est
toujours un honneur d'aller à
l'Assemblée nationale mais à un moment
donné il faudra que tout ce qu'on se dit
et qui semble susciter un consensus
deviennent une réalité pour les enfants
violets
parce que si on tolère le risque que
peut-être oui il va y avoir des
professionnels qui vont penser que il
vaut mieux dire à un enfant violet
attention ton agresseur risque d'aller
en prison mais vous savez ce que ça
génère chez l'enfant c'est je n'ai rien
dit
non non j'ai oublié ce que je voulais
vous dire
alors de grâce et des nous à ce que ceci
deviennent une doctrinationale on vous
dira c'est un parti pris ces militant
oui c'est vrai protéger les enfants
c'est un acte militant alors bien sûr
mesdames et messieurs les députés il
faut armer les professionnels et
principalement dans le cadre du repérage
les professionnels de l'école
Ernestine renais quand elle était
psychologue scolaire le dit souvent elle
posait la question des violences à tous
les enfants et aux parents
parfois les enfants ou les adultes
disaient non moi je suis pas victime de
violence et parfois ils revenait plus
tard elle revenait plus tard s'agissant
des mers mais des enfants aussi bien
est-ce que tu peux me reposer la
question que tu m'avais posé
alors moi je pense que l'école ne peut
pas porter toutes les missions monsieur
le député vous avez raison et peut-être
que elle doit instruire les enfants et
pour que les enfants s'instruisent et
apprennent
pour qu'ils puissent grandir il faut
qu'il soit en sécurité
et donc le repérage systématique des
violences et
d'une certaine manière fait partie
intégrante de l'éducation c'est à dire
du rapport à la loi de l'instruction du
rapport à la loi parce que quand on
grandit en apprenant que la loi c'est la
loi du plus fort qui est dans l'impunité
la plus totale
alors on grandit dans une défiance à
l'égard de la loi et je pense que
la lutte contre les violences sexuelles
et la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles
est de l'ordre des quelques priorités
qui font partie des missions qui doivent
incomber particulièrement à l'éducation
nationale et peut-être avez-vous vu il y
a quelques semaines dans Envoyé Spécial
un documentaire sur la civisme ou une
jeune femme qui avait été victime de
violences sexuelles dans son enfance ce
témoignait dans le documentaire et elle
disait mais après tout ce qu'on fait à
l'école pour la sécurité routière c'est
très bien
on peut le faire aussi pour protéger les
enfants qui sont victimes de viol
et je pense qu'à la raison
armé les professionnels je ne peux pas
vous dire autre chose que vous mentrez
notre proposition de contenu qui est
aussi
précise dans les constats des violences
que dans les guides pratiques qui sont
donnés aux professionnels les questions
à poser les choses à ne pas dire
les personnes à appeler
et je pense que c'est ce que nous en dit
à la fois les les administrations
publiques qui ont contribué à la
production de ce livret et les
professionnels qui l'ont déjà reçu il a
une grande utilité
évidemment on a annoncé les visites de
dépistage systématique
aux primaires au collège au lycée
le président de la civisme ne pourrait
pas dire autre chose que il faut
amplifier ce mouvement
ce qui implique qu'il y ait des médecins
des infirmiers des assistantes sociales
dans les établissements scolaires des
psychologues scolaires
bien sûr que il faut que ces
institutrices et ses professeurs et des
professionnels plus spécifiquement
formés allez voir tout de suite
et bien sûr que il faut que l'enfant
puisse avoir que il y a un espace de
soins où il pourra révéler ça donc oui
je pense que ça va coûter de l'argent
mais je le redis toujours moins que
l'impunité des agresseurs
et après tout la civisme est née du
constat d'une urgence politique
c'est-à-dire la nécessité de créer cet
espace de solidarité qu'est notre appel
à témoignage et cette urgence politique
peut se traduire aussi dans dans les
budgets qui sont alloués
à la médecine et à la prévention
scolaire je pense que ces deux aspects
répondent à la question pour pour armer
les professionnels et notamment les
enseignants mais je peux préciser si
vous le voulez alors Monsieur le Député
monsieur portier en effet il y a une
multiplication des outils des numéros on
craint beaucoup que la multiplication
génère de la confusion
moi j'ai toujours eu la possibilité
d'aller trouver où je voulais les outils
dont j'avais besoin au moment où j'avais
besoin de les utiliser le vademecom de
l'éducation nationale sur
le repérage des violences
est un document
très intéressant et très bien fait et
d'ailleurs avec l'accord de du ministère
de l'Éducation nationale nous avons
repris la page sur le signalement dans
notre livret de formation pour que les
messages soient bien cohérents cohérent
dans une doctrine
il me semble que
l'étape juste après c'est la question
des droits de l'enfant peut-être
monsieur monsieur le député et Monsieur
baladant vous avez raison
je crois que je pourrais vous dire au
risque de vous heurté mais je ne crois
pas que je suis plus le juge des enfants
des besoins fondamentaux des enfants que
des droits de l'enfant
et comme le dit souvent l'une de nos
membres Fabienne kiriot dont vous
connaissez sans doute l'immensité de
l'oeuvre dans la protection de l'enfance
les droits de l'enfant sont
l'aboutissement du respect de ses
besoins fondamentaux tel qu'ils ont été
modélisés par la démarche de consensus
sur les besoins fondamentaux et
notamment les besoins universels des
enfants les besoins physiologiques et de
santé les besoins d'appartenance
d'estime de soi d'exploration de limites
d'identité et avant tout le méta besoin
de sécurité c'est-à-dire la continuité
affective et relationnelle avec une
figure de sécurité ou d'attachement
cohérente
et si la législation sur les enfants
madame la Présidente puis-je faire une
parenthèse
je suis la législation sur les enfants
la résidence des enfants
les modes de résidence des enfants
pouvaient tenir compte des besoins
fondamentaux des enfants
plus
que des projections
de mouvement très organisé
sur ce à quoi devrait se conformer un
enfant pour faire plaisir à ses parents
le juge des enfants que je suis je parle
en mon nom vous en serez reconnaissant
donc d'abord je vous répondrai sur la
question des besoins et sur l'éducation
et l'éducation au droit je suis
absolument d'accord avec vous monsieur
le député incluant une question toute
particulière sur la loi et la violence
moi j'ai toujours pensé que mon rôle de
juge des enfants
était de créer un espace de pensée par
le langage à l'audience et cet espace de
pensée d'élaboration est constituée par
l'écart entre le réel vécu par l'enfant
et la loi
et il faut nommer les deux
donc il faut nommer la violence et
nommer la loi qui l'interdit
et dans cet espace alors on peut
élaborer sur les droits à condition que
l'enfant soit en sécurité c'est-à-dire
que on ne peut pas lui parler de droit
tant qu'on ne le met pas en sécurité
je pense que
l'étape d'après le repérage et les
droits c'est la procédure pénale et
l'enquête pénale et donc les unités
d'accueil pédiatrique enfant danger et
les salles Mélanie et puis le la place
de l'enfant dans les procédures pénales
et la loi du 21 avril 2021
oui l'un de nos membres qui est gendarme
a attiré notre attention sur ce point
et je le dis pour ma part de cette
manière là il faut pas seulement
raisonner en termes de dispositif
ou d'affichage de dispositifs mais de
contenu de décision qui sont prises dans
ces dispositifs en termes de protection
et donc nous avons compris que
dans certaines zones et notamment les
zones les plus rurales le plus souvent
les zones gendarmeries pour aller à
l'uapp ou à la salle Mélanie
il fallait faire 3 heures de route avec
un enfant et qu'il arrivait lessivés
pour le moment de l'audition
à nouveau j'y reviens il faut tenir
compte de l'enfant réel donc
raisonnons en termes de dispositif
uaped et sale Mélanie oui c'est une
évidence dans un maillage territorial
qui permet à tous les professionnels
d'agir de façon sécurisée
et de recevoir les enfants dans des
conditions sécurisées mais un niveau de
formation
à la hauteur de l'engagement budgétaire
dans les dispositifs oui il faut que il
y ait les policiers et les gendarmes qui
soient formés au recueil de la parole de
l'enfant
et que ces policiers et gendarmes est
pour mission de recueillir la parole des
enfants victimes et pas d'autres
missions
formation
spécialisation sélection des
professionnels chargés de la lutte
contre les violences faites aux enfants
et les violences conjugales
j'ai entendu dans votre question madame
la députés madame dupréchirat aussi
quelque chose qui est pour moi une très
grande préoccupation qui est le fait que
des enfants victimes de violence
notamment de violences sexuelles
des personnes victimes de violence
peuvent finalement subir pendant les
procédures pénales et les procès pénales
une victimisation secondaire c'est à
dire que leurs besoins soient non
seulement pas pris en compte mais bafoué
et que l'audience le procès devienne
un moment de traumatisme pour la victime
et je le dis d'une formule
qui me paraît très importante un procès
n'est pas un terrain vague où tous les
coups sont permis
et ça aussi un jour il faudra bien le
mettre en œuvre
on n'a pas le droit de tout faire on n'a
pas le droit d'agresser un enfant ou une
victime à l'audience devant la société
ça me paraît la moindre des choses et
donc
je pense oui que l'enfant victime dans
la procédure pénale doit bénéficier d'un
avocat spécialement formé
et peut-être beaucoup plus souvent qu'il
ne l'est d'un administrateur Adobe
parce que moi comme juge des enfants
j'ai vu des parents et je les comprends
quand le parent n'est pas l'agresseur
évidemment des parents qui étaient très
en difficulté pour ce qui concerne
l'indemnisation du préjudice
qui pensait pas demander un avocat parce
que c'est cher ça pouvait l'être en tout
cas dans certains cas et
qui disait c'est pas l'argent qui compte
sauf que dans la vie quand même ça
compte et donc l'administrateur adoque à
condition qu'il soit formé qu'il
bénéficie d'un statut protecteur est un
professionnel qui permet de prendre en
compte l'enfant et
Nathalie Mathieu dans le cas des
activités de la Maison Brue et avait
fait un déplacement au Québec il y a
quelques mois et nous avons auditionné à
la civisme il y a quelques jours la
responsable de d'un programme
d'accompagnement de l'enfant témoin dans
les procédures judiciaires pour soutenir
l'enfant et lui permettre de de que sa
parole soit mieux prise en compte et
qu'il ne soit pas sur victimisé pendant
pendant les procédures c'est absolument
fondamental
je ne sais pas si je dirais qu'il faut
que l'avocat soit systématique dans
toutes les procédures notamment la
procédure d'assistance éducative je le
laisse à votre réflexion j'ai réfléchi
moi-même l'avocat porte la parole de
l'enfant un enfant de quelques jours de
quelques mois de tout petits étages et
entendu par le juge des enfants en
assistance éducative mais
que dire de la parole qu'il ne prononce
pas il y a des professionnels qui sont
chargés de faire valoir ses besoins
fondamentaux
et je répondu à toutes les questions
je vous ai parlé du livret de formation
de la civisme et de la doctrine
nationale vous ai-je parlé de la loi du
21 avril 2021
voilà un exemple de législation
impérative ce seuildage que les gardiens
du temple ont refusé très longtemps
alors qu'il est conforme à la raison et
aucun principe n'est conforme n'est
contraire à la raison il fallait qu'il
soit écrit dans la loi que lorsque
l'enfant a moins de 15 ans moins de 18
ans dans les cas d'inceste on n'a pas à
lui demander
tu étais d'accord as-tu été pas d'accord
est-ce que tu as crié pourquoi tu as pas
crié
on peut envisager d'aller plus loin
encore bien sûr sur les conséquences
civiles de la violence sexuelle
suspension de plein droit de l'autorité
parentale retrait de l'autorité
parentale je compte sur vous pour que
les deux soient présents dans ce qu'on
annonce comme projet de loi justice à
compter de à compter de 2023 c'est très
important c'est cohérent
et peut-être à réfléchir aux marges de
ce qui a été fort bien structuré dans la
loi du 21 avril 2021 la question de
l'inceste entre majeur de l'inceste
entre mineurs et de l'écart d'âge la
civisme dès le 21 avril 2021 tu es
plutôt sur quatre ans que 5 ans dans les
cartes d'âge
je j'ai pensé que nous devions quand
même dire un mot décidèrent violence
dont nous n'avons pas parlé
[Musique]
et nous avons envoyé le livret de
formation à tous les cabinets et nous
sommes en contact avec
évidemment
quand on nous sollicite et sans
exclusive et donc nous nous espérons que
sur ce livret de formation
il sera repris par les ministres à qui
vous l'avez envoyé
à qui nous l'avons envoyé et qu'il
pourra constituer la doctrine nationale
bien sûr si les enfants sont une
priorité alors cela se verra
merci beaucoup monsieur juge est-ce que
certains de nos collègues avaient un
autre sujet que vous vouliez évoquer
allez-y
merci madame la Présidente je vais être
très rapide parce que leur tour merci
Monsieur le co-président pour la qualité
de votre exposé pour la qualité de votre
travail aussi dans les délais
relativement contraints pour le moment
je voulais vous interroger sur un sujet
parce que vous avez évoqué dans votre
propos liminaire les 1000 condamnations
par an et vous avez dit que cela
décrivait un système d'impunité des
agresseurs je crois que c'est
l'expression que vous avez utilisé
il y a un sujet qui ne figure pas dans
votre rapport mais qui est à la marge et
qui ne
figurez pas dans le périmètre pour m'en
parler de de votre travail qui concerne
la question de la prescription dans le
cadre d'inceste sur personne mineure
alors
on connaît évidemment les arguments à la
faveur de cette de cette prescription
certains ne
des victimes attentes qui est
prescription pour parler et par
conséquent
certaines pourraient
imprescriptibilité pour décourager la
libération de leur parole mais j'entends
aussi celles et ceux qui qui considèrent
qu'il faut beaucoup de courage et
beaucoup de temps pour déposer plainte
pour viol à fortiorer contre un membre
de sa famille
l'amnésie traumatique aujourd'hui de
nombreuses victimes n'est plus à
démontrer j'ai j'ai cru lire dans une
enquête de Lipsos 2019 que 52% des
victimes d'incestes auraient connu des
périodes d'amnésie qui ont duré plus de
20 ans et donc je voulais connaître
peut-être plus encore la position du
juge sur cette question de
l'imprescriptibilité des crimes sexuels
sur mineur
merci chers collègues si je peux me
permettre de rajouter deux petits points
au juge effectivement
on fait de plus en plus avec les usaped
les auditions vidéos pour ne pas faire
répéter la
parole à l'enfant or on continue à
retranscrire
derrière par les forces de l'ordre ce
cette audition pourquoi et seriez-vous
en tant que juge pour la casquette juge
pourquoi ne pas visionner tout bonnement
ces vidéos plutôt que de refaire
transcrire c'était la première chose la
deuxième chose sur l'avocat j'ai bien
entendu sur l'avocat je sur la partie
éducatif moi je plaide pour un avocat
tout le temps je sais qu'on a encore du
chemin à faire mais par contre j'ai
j'avais poussé le fait d'attendre que
l'enfant soit prêt à revoir son parent
dans tous les cas de violence
aujourd'hui c'est difficile
effectivement beaucoup de juges imposent
cette reprise de contact j'aurais voulu
avoir votre votre avis là-dessus et pour
terminer quand vous parlez d'accompagner
l'enfant dans les procédures j'ai pu
voir moi les chiens d'accompagnement
judiciaire
aujourd'hui on a un débat sur comment
les forme qui les pilotent et je pense
vraiment qu'on doit déployer ce système
qui est pour moi j'ai vu des enfants
s'ouvrir et c'est magique voilà merci
beaucoup et bien sûr
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le député de
ces questions
[Musique]
un système d'impunité oui j'assume ce
mot
qui est le titre de d'un livre
kernestine renais et moi avons dirigé
sur les violences sexuelles violences
sexuelles en finir avec l'impunité
et je pense que c'est une réalité et
qu'il faut nous donner les moyens de
lutter contre cette impunité
et je viendrai à la question de la
prescription bien sûr
le chien de justice
[Musique]
je leur que on nous a présenté ce
dispositif je m'étais dit voilà il y a
des gens qui qui ont vraiment l'enfant
réel ou la victime parce que s'adresse
pas qu'aux enfants
dans comme objectif
et le programme enfant témoin du Québec
dont je connaissances grâce à Nathalie
Mathieu et
très beau aussi dans cet ordre là parce
que il prépare l'enfant au moment de
l'audition mais vous savez moi il m'a
fallu du temps comme juste des enfants
pour comprendre que je devais garantir
la sécurité d'un enfant à mon audience
que je commettais une violence
supplémentaire si je ne garantis cette
passation
et notamment si je le confrontais à son
agresseur
et ça il faut que il faut y être
vigilant évidemment
à toutes les étapes
l'enregistrement de l'audition de
l'enfance est fondamentale
c'est fondamental pour un très grand
nombre de raisons
vous m'avez interrogé comme je vous
réponds comme juge nous autres nous
avons la culture du dossier
nous vivons avec nos dossiers
et notre manière de travailler et de
d'être dans référence à la loi c'est
d'ouvrir des dossiers
alors
il faudrait que on nous incite
à respecter la culture du dossier mais
aussi à mieux prendre en compte ces
enregistrements vidéo pourquoi et c'est
l'une de nos préconisations
du 31 mars 2022 parce que
le premier objectif de ces
enregistrements et
d'éviter ou de limiter
l'exigence de répétition par l'enfant
des mots du traumatisme
la seconde c'est que
la retranscription sur procès-verbal
d'une audition d'enfant est extrêmement
coûteuse en temps pour un policier ou un
gendarme
plusieurs heures
et la troisième est que
il y a
du non-verbal
et que le non-verbal ne se retranscrit
mal à l'écrit
malgré tous les efforts
c'est possible mais on limite quand même
un peu le risque mais c'est possible
rien n'est parfait je suis d'accord
et puis la dernière c'est que
évidemment 1 2 3 5 10 ans plus tard
quand on voit l'enfant
qui se met à exprimer du dégoût l'enfant
le petit enfant qui se met exprimé du
dégoût au moment où il raconte disons la
scène de crime
et ça devient très parlant
très très parlant
donc c'est peut-être un peu plus un peu
plus coûteux en temps pour les
magistrats parce que évidemment vous
savez la question des moyens vous pour
la justice aussi bien et donc il faut
que il faut que les magistrales le temps
de regarder ses vidéos et je pense que
ça sécurisera la parole ça me permet de
dire et je suis obligé de le faire que
malheureusement nous devons sécuriser la
prise en compte de la parole de l'enfant
au cours des enquêtes et des procédures
pénales parce que il y a une tendance
extrêmement grave à discréditer par
anticipation la parole de l'enfant qui
révèle des violences avec des concepts
anti-victimères comme le concept
d'aliénation parentale
on le sait mais il est toujours là il
rôde il s'infiltre il nuit ce concept
au nom duquel nous supportons l'idée que
des enfants soient contraints d'aller
dormir chez leur violeur
c'est le risque que nous tolérons de
courir
sur le lien les rencontres entre le
parent et son agresseur et c'est aussi
une chose qui m'a fallu du temps pour le
comprendre comme juge que je ne pouvais
pas imposer une visite médiatisée
un enfant
qu'on essayant de trouver l'équilibre
entre le désir ou
la projection des parents de voir leur
enfant et le besoin de l'enfant d'être
en sécurité me disait mais après tout
une visite médiatisée
mais non en une visite médiatisée on
peut mettre par terre un mois de progrès
et de sécurité c'est la différence entre
le lien et la rencontre tel que me
l'enseigner le docteur Jean-Louis
nouvelle pendant la démarche de
consensus sur les besoins fondamentaux
le lien c'est psychique la rencontre
c'est physique
parfois il faut aider l'enfant à ce
délier à ne plus être envahi par la
présence de l'agresseur à l'intérieur de
lui si l'on veut que l'enfant puisse
apprendre à écrire à lire raconter à
jouer à dormir sans être colonisé par la
graisseur
je ne dis pas tout le temps
je dis quand il y a un agresseur
la prescription
alors c'est une question extrêmement
importante et je vous promets monsieur
le député que si j'avais aujourd'hui
un avis clair et tranché je vous le
donnerai en mon nom personnel
mais que d'une part ce n'est pas le cas
d'autres parts il n'est pas question
pour moi d'engager la civisme qui est
une instance collégiale sur une question
comme celle-ci
ce que je puis dire
c'est qu'à ce jour aucun argument
ne m'a convaincu
contre le fait de réfléchir à la
possibilité d'étendre encore les délais
de prescription voire de les étendre à
jamais l'imprescriptibilité
même si évidemment
je suis un enfant français né dans la
deuxième partie du 20e siècle et je sais
ce qu'est un crime qu'on meurtre contre
l'humanité et je le prends en compte
je sais aussi que de nombreux
pédopsychiatres nous ont dit que
l'inceste est un crime contre l'humanité
ou l'humanisation de l'être humain
je sais aussi que
parmi les
18650 ou 19000 témoignages de très très
nombreux personnes adultes nous ont dit
moi j'ai pris perpétuité
et lui il est dans la rue
et que ça m'interroge
parce que il faut que la justice inspire
confiance
aux personnes qui respectent la loi a
commencé par celles qui ont subi la
transgression les victimes
enfin que
vous avez évoqué le fait que certaines
personnes attendaient le dernier limite
du délai de prescription pour révéler
les violences qu'elles subissent
c'est possible je respecte tout à fait
évident
cette réalité je ne crois pas qu'on
n'est jamais subordonné
la création d'un droit
à l'usage potentiel qui en se répète
enfin vous savez comme moi puisque une
juridiction a prononcer une juridiction
civile a prononcer cette décision
très récemment que on comprend qu'il y a
la prescription pénale et la
prescription civile et que il y a
quelques jours un homme qui avait été
victime de violences sexuelles dans son
enfance et pour qui la prescription
pénale était
et je suis avait obtenu la
reconnaissance
du préjudice de l'agression sexuelle ou
du viol et l'indemnisation
puisque la prescription civile ne court
qu'à compter de la consolidation
c'est-à-dire où le préjudice n'évolue
plus voilà des pistes sur lesquelles
nous travaillons
et puis la precise
on en parlera le moment venu peut-être
parce que je veux pas vous prendre trop
de temps mais il faudra penser à la
précivise et à cette nécessité de cette
ce recueil de la parole qui a une
dimension sociale et peut-être même
politique je le dis souvent la parole
des victimes nous oblige nous devons
l'écouter telle qu'elle se donne telle
qu'elle est la société enfin doit
l'entendre vous vous souvenez de cette
jeune fille dans le documentaire
entendre l'indicible qui avait dit à
peine majeur on l'a vécu vous pouvez
l'entendre
et bien je crois que ce temps est venu
je vous remercie de votre attention
ainsi se termine cette audition
exceptionnelle du juge Edouard Durand
devant la délégation au droit de
l'enfant vous pouvez la revoir sur
LCP.fr mais aussi sur la chaîne Youtube
de LCP on se retrouve très bientôt pour
revoir un autre moment parlementaire
très bonne suite de programme